ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show
i'm sitting here with my producer the
great ben avery he sat in traffic for
four
hours to get here that is called
dedication
that is called dedication getting it
done making it happen this guy drives
hours
i went out to dinner with another comic
who goes
how does ben do it and i meant what
dealing with me
no he goes you know the traveling and i
said look it's his job
now this other comic inherited a lot of
money and bought a house
and there's nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with that
but i said it's his job he does his job
have you heard of a job
i went to dinner with him and the
girlfriend and they leave the masks on
the whole time
and i she works in children's television
and i say this i said
this town is full of sick people huh she
goes
no i don't think the people that work in
children's television
she goes they're some of the best people
i've ever met is there anybody worse
than someone who likes their job
if you really love your job i make a lot
of money doing this and i'm lucky to do
it and i don't even like this
so if you really like your [__] job
can you get up and get out of here
life is too short for positive people
i'm telling you that right now if
they're around you get them out
if you are sitting right now with
someone who is smiling at you
and telling you that everything is
possible kick
them to the curb they are dangerous like
a rattlesnake
they are and i know that we've got that
wrong somehow we've kind of flipped the
script on that
i'm just saying candace owens and ben
shapiro
today are all upset because uh a boy
band member
wore a dress on rolling stone
okay and candace owens is going they're
trying to kill traditional masculinity
here's the deal with with that okay
number one
is there a real danger of men in this
country
going to buy gowns that were on the
cover of
vogue magazine if you put a gun
in my mother's mouth i could not even
figure out how to buy
the game of thrones frock that harry
styles was wearing
on on the cover of vogue do you think
anybody in this country is going to
start wearing dessert
hey honey i'm sick of being a man
i'm gonna go buy a vintage dior gown and
wear it around
i'm sick of my [__] i'm sick of
protecting you and bringing home the
bacon
even though i haven't done that because
i haven't had a job because nobody gives
a [__] about that
and i know you need insulin but that's
okay honey just hold it down on the
donuts for a little bit because we can't
afford that
but i feel like i'm in a prison of my
masculinity
so what i want to do is go buy a
designer gown and walk around the house
like i'm cersei
from game of thrones is there a real
danger is that happening
is that happening out there no one can
afford the gown
ben candice nobody can afford the
designer club
nobody can afford to break out of the
prison people are shopping at walmart
and the clothes at walmart are pretty
they're not experimental
they're pretty they're men women and
children which no one can afford
those are the clothes at walmart
i'm sick of masculinity i want to buy an
oscar de la renta gown right off the
runway
and i'm going to wear it in my truck
even though there's not really going to
be that job anymore because
they're going to have self-driving
trucks soon so i guess i'll just wear it
around the park where we'll soon live
can we focus on any of the real pro can
we focus on any of the problems
at all we're talking about
by the way is that masculine debating
what if my grandfather was alive
he would not be talking about harry
styles and what harry styles was wearing
on the cover of [__] rolling stone or
vogue i don't even i think it was vogue
right
the internet's not loading out here the
internet doesn't work folks everything i
say is the truth we don't need the
internet who needs to verify
right you gonna verify like twitter when
trump goes i won and by the way is there
anything better than that
is there anything funnier than every 15
minutes trump tweeting uh
by the way i'm not going anywhere
i know that you think you had an
election but i gotta be honest i won
that and i won't be leaving
so the media and i mean i'm not saying
it's right but just pure funny
nothing is funnier than him going by the
way i know the media
uh thinks there's some definitive answer
here uh but uh
i'm good i'm good right where i am
and uh every you know it's what everyone
said he would do he's doing it
he's doing what everyone said he would
do which is just sit in that office and
tweet
at the end you always go back to the box
go back to twitter
that's where it all ends it begins on
twitter and it ends on twitter
that's how powerful technology is you
could be the president of the united
states he tried to bomb iran this week
supposedly i don't know if that's true
or not
i think they leaked the thing he has to
general he goes by the way can we bomb
iran
they go just go back to twitter just go
back to twitter
you could you could control a nuclear
arsenal and it's still not going to
be as powerful as twitter
just go back to the box type a few
letters get it get it off your chest
we don't need to bomb the nuclear
reactors in iran
we don't need to bomb iran right now
when you've got two months left and the
best thing that people could say about
you is that you were not a warmonger
let's not ruin that right
do a full withdrawal of the middle east
get real gangster
get everyone home tell everyone they're
coming home
and there are some people that think
he's doing that like on the internet
i'll read you know people are like well
trump is trying to fire people at the
defense department because he wants to
uh end the afghan war and i'm like [__]
yeah man
now that's not gonna happen but hey
let's [__] let's do that
if we're gonna do something and the
choices are
bomb iran or end the afghan war
let's end the afghan war that we've been
in for 20 plus years for lithium-ion
i mean it's just
funny it's just funny that in the midst
of this
we've got a lockdown coming again i'm so
mad about this lockdown i'm so depressed
i can't do another lockdown we've grown
this show has grown tremendously we've
made a lot of fun [__]
we've had a lot of great episodes here
but i'm running out of stuff to talk
about i need to leave my [__] house
i need to get out there and have
experiences with human beings
and i just this lockdown this draconi
i mean the news every day now is like
every news article now is like everyone
you know has covent
that's the article they're like everyone
you know has coveted and every nurse you
knew has killed herself
how do you feel what did you go out the
other night and have meatloaf
yeah well there's nurses hanging
themselves now
why why because you had a meatloaf i had
it in a parking lot it doesn't matter
you knew the risks and now everyone is
covered in all the nurses are killing
themselves
in front of their children what but it's
their job i mean shouldn't they just go
to work
people are there's one thing where they
go like this they go
they're they're putting there's a
hospital in el paso texas where
our nurse goes we have a room called the
pit
where we let all the covent patients die
i'm like why is that
happening why are we doing that
why is that allowed everybody's like i
feel so bad have you read the article
about the pit and i'm like i want to
know why there is a pit
why are we putting people in a pit can
anyone explain that
you went out in that tuna tartare now
they're throwing human beings in the pit
in el paso what what
i don't want that i'm losing it folks
i'm losing it i just took ben to a
bentley dealership i don't have the
money to buy a bentley those cars are
000 thank god and i i don't have credit
i can't do anything but
we just walked around a bentley
dealership thank god it was closed
but i'm losing my mind here because i
want to buy a bentley and drive it
through the er at cedar sinai
i wanna i wanna drive my bentley through
the pit
give everybody a glimpse of a nice car
before the end
it's tragic i know this shit's real it's
[__] hard it's horrible reading these
stories
people face timing their loved ones at
the end how ha how
horrible is that face time doesn't even
work
you got your last words and they're
being they're freezing
you're trying to connect to the wi-fi
you're trying to hey can you connect me
to the wi-fi in the pit
the wi-fi in the pit is not good i'm
trying to talk to my mother
ma i'm in the pit
you shouldn't have gone out to dinner
last night you selfish [__]
what i froze i said kant i called you a
[__]
i mean what are we doing here
oh man it's tragic and it's real it's
horrible
yeah it's so sad people are like they
got to go on
they got to go on facetime to say
goodbye to their [__] families
let the family in if i go from covert i
want my family in that room getting sick
with me no face time
i want my boomer father to walk in there
maskless and get sick
i'm having a party in two days i feel
like an idiot
it's gonna be outside but that doesn't
[__] matter
you know i think people are gonna try to
social distance i mean if the kneel boys
come i don't know how much social
distancing there's gonna be
they're just gonna go around and lick
people's faces like the bushwhackers
remember the bushwhackers that tag team
and wwf what my listeners do
and they would grab your face and lick
you when you when you were just there
and it was great and that's what the nel
kids are gonna do
steve will do it he's going to run
around licking people's faces
if they come i just don't know i'm
trying to laugh and all the news it's so
bad
i don't even know what's good now my
friend vanessa i'm the godfather to her
child i'm like is it covered up bad
she's like not really but she's a
sociopath i mean she's a nurse but she's
like nurse ratchet
[Laughter]
you know she goes i gotta go to work
tomorrow and i hate the liver patients
i'm like what she goes i hate him she
goes when a heroin addict gets a new
liver they're real
uh she goes they're real paranoid and
anxious and they're not fun to deal with
i'm like why are we giving heroin
addicts new livers
i'm confused about everything i just
need to buy a bentley
i just need to buy a gown on the cover
of vogue
to break out of the prayer i don't like
being a man no more
well you buy a muumuu like the rest of
us cause we're broke
i only want a gown like harry styles is
wearing
i wear lane bryant tom we have nothing
in this house
i have three pairs of jeans and they're
all elastic band
i have three dresses and the last one i
wore was when we had to go to court for
your accident
i want i want a christian to your gown
what is wrong with these people scandal
sounds like these people are out of
their minds
they're like they're destroying
masculine how about they're destroying
masculinity by no one has a job
how about that how about they're
destroying masculinity no one can go to
work
you see they're not destroying
masculinity because there's a dude in
ohio right now that's like i want to get
gucci [__] croc sandals and walk
around
in a caftan and wear big [__] chanel
sunglasses and palm springs
destroy masculine nobody can provide for
their family that used to be masculinity
providing for your family
i just love a guy like literally sitting
there with his wife and going
i don't feel i feel like i'm in a prison
of gender
and she goes i understand that but you
can't afford
to go buy a gown that this boy band
member wore on the cover of vogue
it's expensive john it's very expensive
and he's like you don't understand my
whole life
i felt like one thing and i was another
thing she goes i don't care what you
[__] feel like
but you go to pay less and get some
pumps
and you go to [__] get a cheap dress
from the goodwill
because you don't got no scratch john
all day we got to do the destruction of
masculinity and all these guys from long
island are getting on board about you
know the guys that have never served in
a war
and yet their their their [__]
facebook profile picture is semper fi
right there they're they're a military
adjacent
everyone in long island has nine flags
on their lawn they've never served one
day
they've never even helped an old person
across the street let alone
served anybody they've never served
anything except they've served
themselves a drink
that's all they've ever served and
they're getting online they're like
thank god
candace is calling out these [__]
[__] trying to make me wear a [__]
dress
go to work you can't do that
because everybody's in the pit we are uh
all these hospitals we've had nine
months to get ready for the second wave
why is there no why is there no
preparedness
there's been eight mo we knew the second
wave was coming
we knew it was coming it's like if
you're in the ocean and one wave knocks
you down
you stand up and you go oh you know what
i bet another wave is coming
and it's gonna hit me the same way maybe
even worse
if you keep getting knocked down by the
same wave and you see kids that are keep
getting knocked down by the same wave
there's a term for that it's called
drowning
and they need to be taken out by a
lifeguard but if you're an adult
you should have some semblance like why
have we not prepared for this
nobody's getting nobody's prepared i
don't understand
can someone help me here why are we
still throwing bodies in a pit
oh god i mean it's crazy
there's all these nurses that are on
facebook and the nurse will be like this
the nurse goes
i can't go on like this today i came in
and they didn't have any ppe i had to
wear the skin of someone who died
last night they fashioned a mask out of
their face
i'm walking around with someone else's
face on and we're just thro we can't
even treat any of these people
we're putting them up we're stacking
bodies in the parking lot and lighting
them on fire
and i go okay hold on a minute didn't we
know this was coming a little bit wasn't
that the differential here
wasn't the differential that we were
gonna prepare a little bit for this one
well the hospital decided that we
weren't
does no one have money are there no
resources is there's no tax base i get
it maybe that's the problem
everyone's talking about the relief bill
that's like not coming if i see by the
way and i love comedy
and i i mean how many how many times are
you gonna say that and i and ben just
looks at me like we know that that's not
true because
as soon as i say that i then i'm gonna
go off on this rant where i'd like
disparage
everything about it but i understand
it's important to save like independent
venues i get it that's my life
i'm not i'm not saying that but let's if
i see one more time
save our stages if i see that
one more time two things down on the
news feed after someone's talking about
something called the pit
where they're just throwing bodies and
throwing people in a room to die in el
paso
by the way does that have anything to do
with corona or is that just the way the
el paso hospital works
they go we've had the pit forever we
just we
we put you in the pit if you look even
slightly sick you go in the pit
and if you get out of it you get out of
it i mean what's next are going to come
out and they're going to be like
there's a fight club of corona patients
we're making them fight it out for
ventilators
are you happy now are you happy we're
making people fight each other
and the winner gets a ventilator i'm
like is there no
planning has no one done any planning
folks
i'm confused i'm genuinely
confused it's ravaging the nation now
and i guess it's ravaging the small town
hospitals
because the larger cities have more of a
tax base
say what do you want about these satanic
pedophiles but some of them paid taxes
i don't know i'm unaware folks i
you know i all i try to do is
honor honor the work you know i honor
the work here i i just
i'm i'm in a perpetual state
of confusion at the news cycle
i don't understand why nine months later
we're acting like we don't know what
this is and we don't know how to treat
it
and we don't know anything and but yet
we also do
and there's a vaccine coming tomorrow
and also never
[Laughter]
and the lockdowns are coming back and
they're not and there's now a curfew
because corona likes to go home at night
and get a good night's sleep
so we're gonna do a curfew and and and
nobody will ever get corona as long as
you're celebrating joe biden's victory
in the street
but if i want to have youtubers over my
house and feed them spaghetti out of a
cheese wheel
i'm a bad person
i don't get it it's truly
mind-boggling i'm unaware and the only
thing that provides me any levity
the only thing that provides me any joy
the only
thing that gets me through my day is the
president refusing to acknowledge
there's been an election
that is the only chuckles i get
the only hoo-ha that i can muster
is the president every 15 minutes going
i won
and i'm not going anywhere
that's the only thing that's giving me
joy and that's a problem
this episode is sponsored by bluetooth
let's talk about something we could all
use more of right now sex great sex well
it's illegal
in most places but whatever um blue chew
is great you take it your penis gets
hard
you know you last longer it's made in
the usa it's prescribed online by
licensed physicians you don't have to go
to the doctor or wait in line
it's even cheaper than a pharmacy and
they prepare and ship it right to you in
a discreet package no awkwardness
you don't need to leave the house okay
how good is that
i love the blue chew it's it's great it
tastes good you just taste it and eat it
you know it's really really good it's
great it
helps you with the pp and they put it in
the butt or the vv
and you get the hard dick and you got
the penis is hard now
it wasn't hard and now it is blue too
blue true that's blue like the color
blue
dummy and chew like you're chewing
blue chew get extra confidence in bed
increase your performance
last longer and leave everybody who's
saying yeah
good job again that's bluee2.com promo
code td that's bluee2.com promo code td
try it free expressvpn privacy is so
important right now you got to safeguard
yourself vpn
is great okay people uh
used it to stream a german on german
netflix somebody used it to stream a
christmas classic
love actually it was so simple hit one
button to change my location refresh
netflix and that's it expressvpn lets
you control where you want sites to
think you're located you can choose from
almost 100 countries so
imagine all the netflix libraries you
can explore and of course it's not just
netflix
wink expressvpn works with any streaming
service
disney hulu bbc iplayer you name it
just keep it legal and moral out there
that's all i ask keep it legal and moral
express vpn works with all your devices
too including phones tablets media
consoles and smart tvs so you can use it
to watch whatever you want
on the go or the big screen
call to action oh if you visit my
special link right now expressvpn.com
tim dillon you can get an extra three
months of expressvpn for free support
the show
watch what you want and get your holiday
fix at expressvpn.com
tim dillon expressvpn.com tim dillon
the disintegration of the american
system
is proving to be
the greatest comedy ever released
truly i mean there's nothing funnier try
to think of anything
funnier i i mean it's hard borat 2
is the worst movie i've ever seen in my
life
woke borat it's
it's a female forward borat movie
i'm watching this in disbelief like this
is something that i would have made up
with nick mullen two years ago
like what if they do woke borat and now
it's here
and sasha baron cohen is like talking
about
himself he is a comic genius but he's
talking about himself like he's paul
revere
and he's like you're you're bored it's a
movie about a guy who comes from a
country where he thinks all jews have
horns
and you've somehow now infused it with
the right politics
did anyone see borat one and go you know
what
i i just feel that should have had more
of a message
this is where we're at now so we'll
never so apparently we'll never have
anything funny
we'll just never have a good movie again
and the only good movie
that you can watch is the president of
the united states
refusing to leave and do them is the
military gonna have to walk him out
of the oval office are they gonna have
to walk him out
and is all these alt-right kids gonna
stand in the square and cheer for him
as he walks out is he gonna get in a
helicopter like nixon like marine one
and all these little alt-right kids are
gonna be here still my president right
it serves the left right for focusing on
uh russiagate for two years which was
fake
it serves them right for elevating john
brennan the cia director who never met a
drone strike he didn't like
and putting him all over the news
telling people that trump's uh
it was installed by russia for two years
and then and there was all these idiots
that were walking around going not my
president and now we have the other side
that's going to do the same thing so
it's just going to be a
a yin and a yang there's nothing we can
do
there's nothing we can do folks the only
thing we can do is just enjoy enjoy what
you got
save up for that gown on the cover of
vogue magazine
so you can show all your boys down at
the bar that you're sick of having a
[__]
i'm sick of being a man being a man is
not even fun anymore
it's not even good it's like okay
but everybody acts like it's still the
greatest thing in the world and it's
like
get me out of it get me out of the
prison of masculinity put me in a dress
and by the way like what do you think
harry styles people they come in and go
listen
they go listen uh you're in movies
you're in everything you're huge you do
arena tours around the world
vogue wants to put you in a dress
because it's important
for young kids to see that if they too
uh are in a wildly successful boy band
that's put together on a reality show
and parlay that into success as a major
hollywood
actor and if they can like you gross
tens of millions of dollars
that they can be accepted on the cover
of vogue and by the way be gorgeous
because he's gorgeous
so if they're gorgeous and worth tens of
millions of dollars
they can wear a dress on the cover of
vogue it's very important
it's very important for kids to see
i mean it's just crazy we're just
entering a time now
where to try to be serious is to lose
your mind
to try to make sense out of anything
is to go absolutely insane find a hobby
talk about i'm talking about cars now i
never cared about cars
but there's you get to a point where
there's nowhere to go and you have to
start talking about things that are
mundane and you know you have to find
these inane
meaningless hobbies to keep yourself
just even
functional during the day you go oh yeah
yeah yeah well the
you know the bmw 7 series
they have the altena now the all tina's
like the amg package on the pen
and you start to sound like a crazy
person but what else is there to do
get into guns you people love guns
they're like well this one this one's a
good one
because it'll really get you you know i
mean i don't know anymore what to do
i don't know what to do i don't know why
there's zero preparedness for a second
wave that we knew was coming
that everybody knew was coming and
nobody has a clue
nobody's got any way and everyone you
know has covet and everyone's positive
and
and also the tests are fake and they
don't work but everyone's positive
but the tests aren't good but they're
positive
but they're not and and get tested but
don't
and if you have a negative test it
doesn't mean you don't have coven
right so still don't go see your family
and keep the mask on
and then fouchy goes and even if we have
a vaccine you still have to socially
distance
well what do what he said that he goes
even if we get a vaccine
it's only going to work for 90 to 95 of
people so it may not work for you
so it may be good to just leave the mask
on for the rest of your life
just leave the math just eat in parking
lots just get used to eating in parking
lots and having jeff bezos deliver you
gruel with a drone
what's wrong with that do you not like
that
do you not like that you get your gruel
with the drone and you shut up do you
not like that
don't you see where this is going do you
have a problem and then you [__] the
the sex robot because you can't meet
anybody is that not okay for you
do you not like your vegan gruel or
whatever gruel
they're gonna give you it'll probably
have some meat and it's america yeah
but is that not okay that sounds like a
good way forward doesn't it
just don't leave your house just put
sheets on the windows
because the sun's killing you don't go
outside because the air is covered in
fires
stay in your room go on reddit all day
and then become radicalized start
posting get d-platformed
lose your bank account sit there
and just try to order food with your
girlfriend's credit card because she's
not on reddit yet
and she's dead but no one knows that yet
so use her card
while she's dead and then of jeff bezos
and his friends
deliver you gruel and then watch every
now and then you can watch tv and bill
gates will shoot a missile of dust into
the atmosphere
and that'll be and then watch all the
rich people go to mars
eventually that's what's going to happen
you're just going to watch all the rich
people leave
america and ascend they're gonna go to
elysium and you just sit there and don't
go to dinner
but they're gonna go to mars they're
gonna [__] leave and terraform but
you can't go to fridays
because otherwise you're gonna be in the
pit
don't you see it all makes sense doesn't
it make sense
it makes sense the tests are fake but
you have covered
the the masks don't you know they need
to be on all the time even if you've had
it
the antibodies don't matter the tests
aren't real covet is fake
covet is real it's all and all we need
to do now
is just sit in our pod-like homes and
wait for our leaders to let us know when
they're going to leave this planet and
blow it up and be
grateful just be grateful
just be grateful what how lucky are we
and all all that brings you any joy
or that you can just you can just depend
and rely on
is that the president of the united
states who's a game show host
is refusing to leave the white house
it's the only comfort i have
because it makes me laugh and everything
is so
horrible that i don't even and i'm not
saying that covet's not real
and the people aren't sick and that this
isn't horrible i'm only wondering why in
god's name
the most advanced and richest country in
the world has done
absolutely nothing to prepare for a
second wave which everyone said was a
certainty
it was a near certainty and then every
hospital is still in the same [__]
position
that they were in i don't get it i don't
understand
i've made all the jokes already i can't
do another five months of covert jokes
we've done them all we're in a
simulation we keep going
round and round in the circle game
i just don't understand i don't know if
i had it remember when i was sick in
march
yeah yeah your throat closed up
completely i was sicker than i had ever
been
it was wild wildly sick i was sick the
only thing i could do was walk around
beverly hills with persians
all i could do was walk around the
beverly flats and gaze at stunning
estates
while persian kids drive by me in those
little tiny lambos they buy for them you
know the fake
the fake little ones the and all i could
do was walk around and try to get some
sunlight some vitamin d which i don't
know if that even works
and i was sick and i had a cough and
that cough lasted three weeks
and i went to the urgent care in l.a and
the people at the urgent care aren't
real doctors they're actors that are
pretending to be doctors right
they said i had strep throat but rudy
gobert and a lot of those basketball
players also
tested positive for strep throat
apparently it's a common co-infection
i thought i had corona they said i
didn't have it so i went back
i i had a fever i think it was 99 or 100
maybe it popped higher i didn't know i
didn't
give myself the temperature every day
and i just sat there and i felt like
[__] and it took me three weeks to get
back from that and i just felt like
hey maybe i'm just sick you know
but i've been exposed and i've been in
packed planes and i've been
in comedy clubs that have been packed
and i've sat next to strangers and i you
know so either i've just been very very
lucky or i've had this where i have some
what kind of an immunity my mother
has some weird immunity my mother and
i've told this story on stage she
has asthma she's 300 something pounds
she's refused to die
her her neighbor in the nursing home
meaning the person that sleeps in the
bed next to her had it
my mother has not had it my mother
literally wears a maga hat in her bed
like
like she sits there and barks orders at
people like [__] um
like jabba the hutt in her maga hat and
screams at them if they don't bring her
the food and she said it sucks and she
throws it at them
and she tortures all of the health care
workers you know
my mother they throw my mother in a pit
everyone will die but my mother
put my mother in the pit they'll go
patty ate everyone in the pit
she ate two corona patients and now we
got to bring her back to her room
the pit
does anyone can we launch an
investigation into the el paso hospital
like
can anyone explain i wish we had the
internet we could look up the pit
i'm just so confused
i feel like nothing is changing i feel
like we're we're in a weird simulation
we're in a roller coaster we're about to
do the we're about to do another loop
you know did you see a lot of
celebrities are still doing
international travel like tom hanks got
his like
greek citizenship and they're taking
pictures in greece and all these things
like they're still allowed to go
wherever they want and uh kim kardashian
got an island and all these things
the celebrities are still living their
life there's no quarantine for them
really
there's no quarantine for anybody that's
got real money
and they're not they're gonna leave the
planet earth
soon and we're gonna we're gonna have to
sit there and go isn't it great
isn't it great look at carrie underwood
though
look at taylor swift leave earth i mean
this is what they're getting ready for
they're get it's islands now but in 20
30 50 years it's gonna be
planets they're out yeah they're trying
to get
out they really want out yeah but you
can't go to ralph's
right but if you go to ralph's you've
killed someone because you got macaroni
salad
but these people can can launch rockets
and try to get the [__] out of here
i don't blame them if i had that kind of
money i'd get the [__] out of here too
these elites are like what are they
arguing about now they're arguing about
uh harry styles were dressed they're all
inflamed over that they look at each
other going let's get out of here
let's get out of here can we can you get
elon musk on the phone and richard
branson a few people can we make a few
things happen and get out of here
jesus and max was like i was our biggest
problem we're in ireland we should have
had a little [__] planet
me and jeffrey could have had a planet
the next jeffrey epstein's gonna have a
planet
he's gonna have a planet i'm thinking
like did you hear what happened on
uh little saint jupiter
it's truly and we're all supposed to sit
here
and think it's great and fight each
other we're all supposed to scream in
our aunts and uncles
and not see our families and not leave
our houses and not ask why we can't go
to work
and not ask what's going on and we get
nothing from anybody
and we've elected joe biden who is he's
a real jfk figure and i mean jfk now
like dead and we've got kamala harris
who's gonna get in there and if you ask
a question you're gonna be put right in
jail
and you're gonna need like five vaccines
to go to macy's
so what are we doing
we're so medicated in this country it's
all anxiety and depression
nobody wants to talk about the fact that
is it anxiety or depression or is it
that
you don't have a job you you don't have
a family you ate a stack of pancakes and
now you're asleep
and you're sleeping and you have no
future and it's been robbed and taken
from you
and uh but you're but take this pill
it's gonna be okay
and your kids all have adhd which means
they just want to go outside
and run around and get but they can't do
that
because you know the streets you know is
crawling with
pedophiles and god only knows so we're
terrified now the kids can't even run
around anymore they just sit and
they just sit on twitch and watch other
people play video games while they eat
[__]
skippy peanut butter with their fingers
yeah and blink a lot because yeah that
[__] you up
so here's [__] some adderall for them
and then you have to take nine million
dollars out in college loans
and then you gotta sit there and you're
getting a degree in in in
in whether you have a [__] or not and
then you wonder how am i going to pay
that back well just keep cramming
adderall down your throat and write a
thesis on your horrible life
and then then you're going to have to
spend the rest of your life paying back
student loans
selling your blood plasma but don't
worry it's anxiety
it's not the system it's anxiety it's
depression
it's chemical it's in your head it's all
in your head
don't ask us for a solution it's all in
your head here's eight hundred dollars
go die
and we can't question the pharmaceutical
companies because then you sound like a
then it's like what are you some
anti-vaxxer are you some nut
do you not trust bill and melinda do you
not like pfizer
do you not like merck and novartis and
glaxosmithkline
do you not like that do you not like a
generation of drugged up americans who
are on so many ssris their dicks don't
work
and then you got to get pills for that
shout out to blue chew
but is you can't question them you can't
question them the only family we're
allowed to hate is the sackler family
because they are scumbags and they made
oxycontin and they didn't want to tell
anyone it was illegal but we're supposed
to
we're supposed to believe that they're
like some lone wolf
just like lee harvey oswald see the
sackler family they're bad but they're
just a lone wolf
everyone else is great they're all yes
they were on epstein's island doing a
conga line with bill gates but they're
all good
the sacklers are bad they're bad because
they made oxycontin and
then we have the uh opioid addiction
well what about all the people that ship
the jobs away
shut your mouth nazi it's the sackler
family
well shouldn't we ask some of the other
pharmaceutical companies what the [__]
they're doing
no they're benevolent forces for good
and you take this vaccine with 19
boosters
well will the vaccine work we don't know
we're trying to leave
earth can you stop bothering us
here harry styles isn't a dress go fight
about that
and by the way the kids are going home
from school so now you have your
children to deal with as well
and there's nothing you can really do
other than just
enjoy
have a few have a few smoke a joint
do something run swim get on the
elliptical try to stave off
you know whatever disease is coming for
you which you can't afford
right you know joe biden's new health
care plan will i don't know what it'll
be but it'll be nothing
you know oh yeah it'll be absolutely
nothing and don't worry as soon as those
two get in we'll be at war again which
we need another war
yeah we need to get in there we've been
giving saudi arabia money
so they can go and shellack yemen
causing a genocide they need more money
and then israel will need more money and
then everybody will need more money
so that they could go to the middle east
and continue to play guacamole with the
middle east
while you and everybody you know
disintegrates into quicksand
and there's nothing really to do except
oh it's barry weiss on the view
barry's on the view barry and megan are
really gonna give it to each other on
the view
just a little frustrating so i just walk
around the bentley dealership when it's
closed
just touch the bentley grilles and it's
closed i just touched the bentley
grilles
and i tried to explain to ben no this is
the newer grille
it's the newer i'm like a lu i'm like
rain man i walk around like a
psychopath i just touch the bentley
girls i put my face
i feel the little grill on my face
wouldn't it be nice to get hit by a
bentley
wouldn't it be nice to have your face
smashed by a bentley
wouldn't it be nice in front of a family
in front of a
family on vacation wouldn't it be nice
what happened to that man
well that man just got hit by a bentley
and then there'd be blood on the grill
and some [__] will get out
and she'll look at you and you'll be
staring at her with your bloody face and
you know you only got a few minutes left
of life and she just
looks down at you and the last thing she
does is just put a mask
on your diseased little face so she
doesn't have to look at it
i don't know what to do or where to go
it's truly interesting
and it's not here's the thing it's not
even interesting no one cares about the
pc [__] anymore you can't even argue
about that i see people making sketches
about that it's over
that is over guys what a luxury problem
to have
it's a luxury problem to have no one
cares about
no one cares about getting earth is
getting
canceled earth the planet earth is being
cancelled
you're living through the cancellation
of the planet earth
right now and it's hard it's hard to
ignore it
because they're all about to leave
they're all about to go
they're just gonna get on jets and
they're gonna get on spaceships and
rocket ships and you're gonna watch them
go they're gonna say it's great
they're gonna go isn't it great isn't it
great they're all
leaving to go somewhere else
and you could sit there thanksgiving's
coming up isn't that fun thank god we
have thanksgiving
shouldn't we cancel thanksgiving
is there anything to be thankful for
this year is there anything to be
i mean can you ima i guess you could be
thankful you're alive
you could be thankful you're not dead
that's true you could be thankful you're
not in the pit
right i get it you can be thankful maybe
you're working you can be thankful you
got some money
there are things to be thankful for no
doubt but
it's a lean time for gratitude
isn't it a lean season for granted
and by the way any company that does a
jingle bells christmas
commercial we should surround it with
ar-15s
if you said i'm kidding about that which
is comedy
comedy comedy
but if they do that [__] this year with
the goofy like
hey it's a different kind of christmas
this year we know
like if they do that and you know that's
coming right
there's going to be a snowman on a
ventilator
it's a different kind of christmas this
year yeah santa claus on a zoom call i
can't see it now santa's on a zoom call
everybody's saying hello to each other
from zoom
we know you can't be together this year
but it's important that you just
constantly accept everything we say
because it's the only way
it's the only way any of you are going
to get anywhere by the way
christmas is coming deck the halls with
boughs of harley
god am i not in the mood for that i
don't want to hear any christmas music
this year
i want funeral dirges and gregorian
chant
i hope these radio stations just play
gregorian champions
that's all i want to hear i want to hear
funeral dirges
and gregorian chant i do not want
any [__]
peppy happy christmas music
this year i don't feel it's appropriate
you know and i i know that
i hope they do sanikon and i hope they
call it covidcon
sienacon is when all these young kids
dress up like santa clauses
and elves and mrs clauses and they all
run around
and i hope to god they do it this year i
hope to god they do it and the cops
shoot them and they still do it i hope
that they shoot a bunch of white kids
and those white kids are just just
drinking eggnog and vomiting [__] in
the streets
and their cops are just blowing their
brains out
it's a different kind of christmas this
year we
know that here at amazon we know it's a
different kind of christmas
which is why we're reminding you that it
is completely unsafe
to leave your house or make human
contact with anyone
for any reason because what you see
as just a fun-loving little christmas we
see
as a resistance movement
you see it as a family gathering the fbi
sees it
as a domestic terrorist organization
do you understand me don't ask any
questions
it's a different kind of christmas this
year
you'll just need to stay in your just
stay
now it would be like now it would be
like anne frank
hiding from the nazis now it would be
like
and you stay there forever wait the
war's over
anne and do you want people sent to the
pit what's the pit
get back in the closet wait a minute
they just liberated all the camp and
i'm telling you right now get back in
the closet you can go on zoom
[Laughter]
what's great about car insurance is that
nothing is great about it but you gotta
at least get really good cheap car
insurance so you go to gabby
gabby is easy it takes the pain out of
shopping for insurance by giving you an
apples to apples comparison of your
current coverage with 40 of the top
insurance providers like progressive
nationwide and travelers just link your
current insurance account
and in just minutes you'll be able to
see quotes for the exact same coverage
you currently have
it's very easy to use gabby i just did
it i just got a car it's so cool
like i mentioned earlier gabby customers
save 961 dollars
per year on average i bet that'd be nice
to have in your pocket every year if
they can't find you savings like they
did for me they'll let you know
so you can relax knowing you may have
the best rate out there and they'll
never sell your info
so no annoying spam or robocalls
telling you you're probably overpaying
on car and home insurance see how much
gabby can save you it's not only for the
car ben it's also for the home
did you know that i didn't yeah well you
do
totally free to check and there's no
obligation go to gabby.com
tim dillon that's g-a-b-i dot com
tim dillon gabby.com tim dillon and
let's see
folks are you spending too much money on
car insurance and home insurance
and if you are gabby is going to tell
you how to change it and if you're not
then you just rest in the glory
as maria bamford would say rest in the
glory that i am wrong
uh just rest in the glory that you are
killing it
when me and ben are out people always
compliment his ventura watch they love
it it's very nice and it doesn't break
the bank i'm telling you they're so
beautiful they make the perfect kiss
gift gift especially with the holidays
coming up plus they offer engraving on
the back of their watches so pick out a
watch or write something special on the
back for a loved one or for yourself
get your hands on one now before it's
too late with vincero there's no brand
name markup no big name price tags
no big time price tags their promises to
you is simple their promise to you is
simple
solid well-made products you will enjoy
wearing these guys know just how
important it is to shop from local
brands you can trust
the chair offers free shipping 30-day
returns and guarantees for your watch
for two years they believe in doing
things the right way so if customers get
the best and never have to settle
this is why they have over 25 000
five-star reviews because you won't find
a better maid watch
for this good of a price anywhere else
visit v-i-n-c-e-r-o
venturawatches.com backslash tim
venturawatches.com backslash tim to
access the site-wide sale to get
get a watch get a watch
i would get a watch when they start
paying me more i'll get one
get a watch everyone it's so cool to
have a watch
and you'll be like what time is it i
know the time it's a great way to break
the ice with a with a lady
she goes hey do you have the time
because
i guess your cell phone is dead and
she's blind
so she goes you have the time and you go
yeah i know
it's time for you to be my [__]
anyway by the watches fox automatic 15
off entire order and they cover all
shipping costs promo code tim
how cool is that 15 off entire order we
cover all shipping cost promo code t-i-m
finchero
watch us thank you
i mean it's just a you know
i hope i was funny when i get into
depressed mood i tend to be funny doug
stand up had a great quote
he said happiness is great for a lot of
things but it ain't good for comedy
not the type of comedy i do there's a
lot of comedy out there that's very
happy and god bless the people that do
it
i really don't that's not for me you
ever seen like happy comedians
it's terrifying it's actually scarier
than angry comedians
guys that are really happy like hey man
what's going on how you been where you
been
hey man
like a clown have you ever been like on
a date and then you fart
why does why do these people need to
make anyone laugh
just go and play volleyball
[Laughter]
i look at some come on i look at some
comics on a stage i go will you just go
and play volleyball please
stop wasting everyone's goddamn time
have you ever been on the beach and then
you [__] yourself
the coyotes all around the desert are
screaming they agree with me
i'm moving from the desert i'm moving
back to the valley of california
to love los angeles for a year we're
doing one year in l.a we'll see what
that means
who knows me and ben move as a unit so
we'll make a decision after that maybe
we go end up in texas i don't know
i'll move to texas if joe rogan's the
governor
maybe i'll get into politics like
everything's fake
so maybe i'll just run for congress you
know i get bored
easily so i'm like maybe we should just
run a congressional
campaign ben could we do the podcast on
the is that legal
you still have why not uh bernie had a
podcast at one point so it's probably
illegal yeah yeah
i'm telling you right now i think we
should just run for congress as a bit
yeah let's just run as a joke
we should just run for congress as like
a bit let's do it
uh you're my campaign manager okay and
they'll be like uh mr dillon uh
uh is openly talked about paying for sex
and
um uh selling subprime mortgages
and uh he's he loves dishonesty
and he's a a moral degenerate he has
many failings he's
asked the nursing home many times to
kill his own mother
and he would take a percent and say it's
covered he'll take a percentage of the
money
mr dylan do you have any uh i'll just do
the milk thing i'll just look and go hey
full send bro full send
i'll run for president but steve will do
it he's going to be my vice president
that guy drinks like that's like i'm
starting to love those guys because like
everyone else is like garcetti is not
defending the cops
and then elk is like what if we drank a
bottle of rum
at once like in one chunk
it's refreshing i'm like yeah they're
like let's make out on some old guy
who's in a
grocery store probably some old veteran
so what that guy can get made out on
what is it
he probably did the mile massacre
not saying everything they do is super
moral but it's fun it's a little
different you know
sure instead of tweeting at a garcetti
about uh
defunding the police all day these kids
are like what if we just
harass people in a grocery store sounds
fun
folks i don't even know what to do
anymore i'm
i'm just you know how long have we done
on this episode
we're at uh 47 right now
47 minutes of just bile just straight up
bile leaving my soul it's really amazing
straight up bile louie said i spoke to
ck about the show he goes
he goes do you plan any of that i'm like
no i just
i just go i love louie louie's a great
guy
and i i think that when when the facts
come out and they never will probably
you know no one will care but it will
exonerate him on many levels
totally absolutely
not that that's a you know he's still
working people are still following him
and going to his shows
comic genius you know yeah but
no one cares you could talk to people
they don't care i took to women in long
island i go what what about louie they
go what
what do you mean right
i don't know man it's just it's just an
interesting
and it's not interesting i got to keep
stopping myself it's actually boring i'm
bored
the news cycle like the great eddie
pepito said there are so many shootings
i'm bored by them
the news cycle has gotten boring
every day you turn on the new okay so
everyone's dead okay
can't leave the house k trump's not
leaving k
k okay
the big thing now is like are you gonna
go see your family that's the big
and you know how i feel about that don't
go and it has nothing to do with corona
right
but that's the whole thing everybody's
like are you gonna go see your family
because if you do
you're gonna kill but i love when they
do these things they were like from one
wedding
150 cases of cover 19 and seven deaths
who is doing that like who's doing the
tracing
like that's the fun job right who's
doing that
what historian is on that beat
the wedding covered beat all right so
you attended the mccleskey wedding okay
and then you got sick and then you went
to denny's and then a waitress dropped
dead
i mean who's doing this rust cole
how are we doing this is there's just a
guy in a shed
somewhere with all these strings of yarn
attached to every human being
that's ever left the house in six months
how are we doing this
web of covert death by the way just
matthew mcconaughey sitting there
smoking a cigarette going
well i knew that the johnsons went to a
baby shower on the 12th
and then they got in their van and drove
two states away
to see their son at college you see what
i'm saying here
it just lights a cigarette like not
really he's like well
it's it's you gotta look at it look at
the big picture woody harrelson's like i
don't [__] know what you're saying
man
russ is like let me pop this tape in
here's a tape
you know and instead of the [__] true
detective kid getting [__] or whatever
it's like
it's like it's just a tape of like a
bunch of people sitting in a backyard
you know eating burgers and woody house
like oh my [__] god
jesus [__] christ man you watch all
that
you watch all that [__] man all right
i'll help you
what do you need well we gotta find
everybody
we gotta find every single person that
went to the miller wedding
shout out to the girls from red scare
who quoted me when they were talking to
grant glenn
greenwald i enjoy them go support
them on patreon if you can if you enjoy
their program
um shout out to everybody on patreon
making money
you know oh yeah before kamala harris
goes in there
with a chainsaw so
[Laughter]
it feels like we will be off there by
the way just enjoy this while it lasts
folks because kamala is going to go in
there with a chainsaw
and start sawing desks apart they're
going to execute the people in this
this [__] site like they're they're
going to stand them on a plank
[Laughter]
oh they're going on a plank by the way
to see your patient he better hope
he better hope that they don't just walk
him right out into the field they're
gonna blindfold him and walk him right
out into the field
you did what you let what happened
so you just let people talk and then
other people give them money oh
no thank you they're gonna
execute everybody at
patreon we hope not
god do we hope not god let's pray
that that doesn't happen i just hope
that there's one guy that saw harry
styles in that gown
and said that i only want to be trans if
i can go designer
i only want to break out of the prison
if i can i can't if i i might just be a
man
if i can't wear a vintage chanel gown
i might just have to be a man like just
some guy sitting with his buddy going
hey man i was ready to be done with it
the farting the fighting chasing [__]
being a [__] man i saw harry styles
in that gown
and then i i saw the gown it was and i
tried to get it
but it's off runway and you can't really
get it in the stores you'd have to call
a stylist or a designer
i don't really know anybody the big
fashion houses have people that reach
out
basically try to get people wearing
their [__] i don't have access to any of
them
so you know what i did i just went to my
shitty job
ate my [__] shitty lunch and i
figured i'd go home and just put my
half hard [__] and my wife again because
i can't afford
to be the golden [__] trans person
i want to be a golden woman or nothing
at all
i just i can't stand this
if i can't have a gown if i can't walk
around like cersei lannister around my
little hovel
then damn it i'll just go to the pit
just throw me in the goddamn pit
we can't afford the gown well then just
throw me in the pit honey
i'll be in the pit you understand
waiting for the end with my dirty [__]
and my disgusting prison of masculinity
i just love the people in the pit
reading ben shapiro
this is disturbing the assault on the
assault on masculinity is really a
problem
it's so dark the news is so
incredibly dark it is so
dark don't fall into depression folks
don't fall in
i know i know that it's so easy right
now because i fight it myself like
i try to fight paying it you know that's
why that little kid dan around because i
love him he's just
he doesn't pay attention you need frat
boys in your life and college kids and
watch the milk videos you can't if you
pay attention
you're it's the problem so that's why
you just gotta kind of say
hey just have fun
just goof just be a goof
you know maybe all those comics i [__]
on maybe they were right the whole
[__] time
talk about farting go play volleyball i
mean you're not allowed
and if you do it the cops will shoot you
or just walk around the bentley
dealership just walk around dealerships
of cars you can't afford after they've
closed
and look at the pretty metal look at the
pretty metal
look at the pretty metal and imagine
those cars as spaceships
and imagine those spaceships leaving the
planet with all your favorite
politicians and celebrities
and all their rich drug addict children
like cheney's that speak in jamaican
patois
they're all gonna get to terraform
they're all gonna get to go to somewhere
else
and we'll just sit on this burning
ravaging hellscape
looking at each other and listening to
our favorite podcasters on patreon
and we'll just hope to god that maybe
some of us get taken up there as
experimental sex
guinea pigs that's our best hope our
best hope is that some of these elite
[__]
look at us and say you know what maybe
they'll be good to just
[__] with their biology so we'll fly
them up there and make them live in
in little huts and we'll make them [__]
each other and we'll try out all kinds
of experimental
vaccines on them and wilma you know
that's the hope
that's the real hope here okay because
that's how this all started
you see that's how earth started the
anunnaki or whatever
alien race was like we need a slave
phrase
let's make them let's let's just [__]
around with them and let's put
biological material on earth
see what the [__] happens and then they
created us
you see and it ain't that bad right
so in a thousand years from now if they
take some of our disgusting carcasses up
to the next planet with them
and they breed us as a slave race then
years later there'll be a new patreon
and there'll be new podcasters and
there'll be new [__] depressed people
walking around
closed down bentley dealerships and
there'll be new dresses
and new vogue magazines and everybody
will be fighting
and then in a thousand years these
[__] will get up and they'll
leave that planet
and they'll just keep going around the
universe like this
and they'll be shape-shifting
inter-dimensional
aliens that feed on our negative energy
and that's okay because that's just
what this is folks it's just what it is
so be happy with it enjoy it hope to god
they put you on a spaceship
hope to god they see something valuable
and they let you procreate
to make a new slave race on their new
planet
but until then i'm gonna go right now
because ben asked to do some research i
saw a very pretty gown
and i want it